[Music]
[Music]
oh hi thank you for joining me for
another video
this is my dog Molly and this is a
wooden wine glass I'm gonna talk to you
about mistakes that people make
networking what a dirty word that is and
I'll talk a little bit about how I've
built my own network as it were my
advice in short is to go narrow and to
go along all right so that involves deep
relationships with a small number of
people and then playing the long game
what many people do is they go to an
event to collect business cards and then
they follow up with people with whom
they have no common interests in the
hopes of some type of transaction in the
near term the next few weeks the next
few months I can work but what I would
suggest you do is if we're looking at
events which can be very very high yield
look at either volunteer events where
you can volunteer all right or super
high-end events where you can attend and
pay premium to attend and in the former
category I can give you an example of a
tipping point for the 4-hour workweek my
first book and that came about by going
in part to South by Southwest 2007 and
my tactic was as an attendee here which
is fairly expensive to go to moderated
panels and then when a panel ended
instead of flooding the scene to get in
line to talk to a panelist I would
actually talk to the moderator who
people tend to ignore and I would be
very very humble to the extent I could
and say it's my first time of South by
Southwest I'm pretty nervous I just
wrote my first book I don't know anybody
not gonna pretend to understand
everything about tech I don't but I'm
really interested in a B C D and E and
I'm originally from this part of the
world and these are some of my interests
is there anyone you think I might enjoy
meeting here now you have say Mary or
Joe whoever saying yeah you should meet
Mike such-and-such
then I go and find Mike or I'm
introduced to Mike and I already have
that social stamp of approval of one
person okay now I meet that person and
we talk and there's no explicit ask it
was really important I do the same thing
just got the South by Southwest my first
time here
I apologize kind of a random
introduction but I don't know anybody
and I have my first book out I really
don't know what to do because I have my
launch coming up but I'm here to learn
that's it I'm here to learn and meet
people I don't even know what to ask for
and talk to them talk to them talk to
them and then if the timing seems right
and it may not may never be right but if
it is you can ask and is there anybody
else here you think I should meet up
with or buy a drink for who can I buy a
round of drinks for just to have fun
cool people who I might be able to hang
out with and who might enjoy hanging out
with me and then you go to the second
person and so on and now all the way up
to this point I have not made a single
ask alright other than the question is
there anybody else you think I might
enjoy meeting now at some point you will
then have a small gaggle of people and
probably you'll be buying booze at least
that's my tactic it's fairly fairly easy
to buy booze for people and then
everyone's talking so let's say you have
a group of people in tech or you have a
dog wants treat is coming back to say
hello a bunch of people in tech we're
talking about tech things and they're
saying things like blah Blee blah Blee
blah Ruby on Rails I don't know what
that is as a guy I'm talking to the guys
here because women generally don't have
this problem don't pretend like you know
everything it's really not endearing so
they would say something like blah blah
blah Ruby on Rails and I would say you
know so sorry to interrupt this is deep
in the end of my ignorance pool I don't
know what Ruby on Rails is what is Ruby
on Rails and every once in a while I
would interject and ask for
clarification just to learn eventually
after two or three rounds of drinks
someone will say who are you again like
what do you do what are you doing here
and then you can offer a little bit you
say something like well
I just finished my first book I'm really
nervous it's coming out on such and such
a date and I don't know what a book
launch is so I'm here to try to meet
people and learn different skills to
figure that out and then you stop you
don't give them a two minute or three
minute pitch and chances are someone
will ask okay well what's your book
about and then you can give a little bit
more and then let's say you're in a
group of eight people you watch the one
or two who are going to have more
follow-up questions and then eventually
maybe in a group of eight people you say
to one of them afterwards you say look I
have a ton of books that my publisher
sent me these are review copies and
advance copies I don't know what to do
with them I don't think you'd actually
read the whole book but there's there's
a 20-page bit then I think you'd really
enjoy on X Y & Z because you know that
you've already ascertained it through
the conversation you had and you say you
know if it wouldn't be a burden if you'd
enjoy it maybe I could send it to you
but if not that's cool
and I would say 90% of the time they
said yeah sure that'd be cool I'd love
to see it and that's how it all happened
guys that's how the book hit them your
toughest self worth list was by doing
that over and over again and this is the
key point you don't have to be a
networking [ __ ] you don't have to sell
yourself to the highest bidder or
compromise and spend time with people
you don't like you can find people who
are a class players in a given world who
you want to spend time with who have
similar values and hobbies so that one
person out of the ten who said yeah cool
no I'd love to check it out the vast
majority of those people from eleven
years ago are still my friends today and
that's going narrow and going long hey
guys if you're enjoying the tips and
tactics and how-to on this channel or in
the podcast the Tim Ferriss show I made
this for you
tribe of the mentors short advice from
the best in the world this is the book
that I wanted to read so I went out and
I put it together
created a dream list a hundred and
thirty of the best at what they do
people who are icons ledge
and ask them all the same questions
these are people in some cases I wanted
to reach out to my whole life ranges
from many many billionaires cofounders
of every company imaginable elite
athletes ranging from surfing to tennis
to powerlifting everything else country
stars actors directors and you can spot
the pattern so some of my friends have
said this is the easiest to read most
useful book that I've put together yet
so check it out tribe of mentors dot-com
you can find sample chapters the whole
list of mentors everything tribe of
mentors calm